say we don't do anything today
in u.s
40 the dollar has been printed whatever
the last two years right that they keep
talking about say we don't do nothing
how bad are things going to be and how
long would it last
well does that include
not uh to increase the the money supply
any further which would be good i mean
we should not increase it anymore zero
nothing else we vote on nothing we say
we're going through this
we're gonna buckle down and go through
this how long will it last and how ugly
will it be
it will depend on the strength of the
community banks the local banks and they
are quite strong in the u.s so i think
the us will
weather this
because small firms will still
receive backing
from their community banks
whereas in more centralized economies
where you also don't have these many
small local banks things would look much
worse
i think that is actually a good policy
at this stage of course we should have
done that ready in 2020.
they took the wrong policies they
created too much money
for unproductive purposes you know all
my work shows that that is wrong
you should only create money for
productive purposes and when i say
create means inject into the economy the
bailout i mentioned before doesn't
inject new money you see that's why
under specific circumstances it can help
you have a healthy banking system but it
should then also have the right
incentives to
to lend for productive purposes so say
say they don't do anything so let me go
back to my question in 2020 you said
they shouldn't have done it they
shouldn't have done lockdowns because if
you exactly force you to lock them then
you have to pay me so they should have
not done the lockdown so you don't have
to give the money because when you did
the lockdown you hurt the restaurants
but today say
we somehow democrats and republicans
both agree on one thing i don't want any
more bailouts
okay
and we drive the hell out of this
messaging we want no more bailouts to
these bigger companies we don't do
nothing
we're going to unite and we're going to
go through this time and these bigger
guys that have been spoiled for the
longest time and they've not been
working let them go through the pain to
see what we went through to come to the
top because you don't know what it is to
go through it right if we don't do
nothing
how ugly will it be how long will it
last so when i ask ugly here's what i'm
asking jimmy carter era you know the
interest rates where they hit right 16
17 18 it's pretty ugly what happened
during that time right and then reagan
came in and he did what he did why did
this happen i studied the 70s and most
people think oh it was an external shock
a supply shock even like today there was
a war and then energy price shock that's
the reason no it's not true
already
um
over one year before because oil prices
only started to rise from late 73 1973
but i can already see in the data of the
central banks and bank credit creation
gold standard a massive expansion from
1971 72
all of them and that's what created that
inflation they then were looking
desperately for a cover so that the
focus is not on them but they created
this inflation it was only sold and
marketed to people as oh it's the oil
price shock it's energy it's the middle
east blah blah it's not true it was the
central banks
that is a fact and
you know they should uh take
responsibility for that unfortunately
they're doing the same thing again now
so the inflation is again created by
then the question then becomes the
market policy so you say central banks
yes okay
but say we didn't do any creative
policies during that time
how long would have those high interest
rates lasted and how different would the
economy have been you see the high
interest rates what i showed with my
earlier study you know reconsidering
monetary policy is interest rates follow
growth and they follow nominal growth
so the the money creation was revved up
a lot in 1971
so one and a half two years later you
get nominal gdp rising and huge
inflation
and that's why interest rates had to go
up interest always follow growth that's
what's happening now it's all
predictable your concern is not interest
rates you're not worried about interest
rates it will be painful for people
clearly with mortgages that are you know
floating mortgages and so on sure and
that's something one should look at as
policy makers
but
in general just looking at the macro
economy and giving a quick answer it's
clear that
what's happening now is the result of
these bad decisions from 2020
we should
stop making bad decisions
doing nothing would be better that would
be a better policy than what they're
likely to do which is
create even more money and accelerate
the inflation which could be very
disastrous
so
it is time to change policy and but also
then to actually question this why do we
have such a system where these wrong
policies are taken
what can be done and
we should look at the strengths of the
us economy and one of the great
strengths is
that there's thousands of small local
banks we need to help them
and make sure that they won't be
squeezed out because the big guys want
to kill them that's what's happening in
europe of course and but they are what's
needed to make sure that your local
small firm will survive they need that
supply because even a tiny local
community bank will create money when it
lends that's like your own local
money creation it should be done for
productive purposes but giving it to a
business small firm that is doing
something productive then it's fair and
transparent how many meetings are being
had right now tom you think
with these big uh bank guys that you
know funded the campaigns of different
uh candidates that are saying oh okay
you don't want to do anything oh okay no
problem yeah don't do anything see what
we're gonna do when it comes on to
reelection time how much you think the
policymakers are afraid of not bailing
out the bigger guys because the bigger
guys have bottom
through campaign support and different
kinds of things or do you think that
does not play a role i think candidates
are scared to death of big banks i think
both sides they all are scared to death
yeah to patrick's question can you
follow up one part that you haven't
addressed yet so he was saying how bad
could it be how do we get out how long
will it last can you go to how long will
it last because you've said how bad
could it be it could be reasonably bad
on interest rates and the average guy
with the mortgage and then how do you
get out we need strong local community
banks helping local businesses that
helps job creation local growth local
economy
taking the pain off the people who just
got hit with their credit card interest
and their mortgage interest right main
street as we call it how long do you
think this will take that was the third
part of pat's question i'd love your
take on that yes well if the scenario is
that we we are not increasing the the
money supply further for the big guys
and we we don't have this inflationary
policy anymore
then it's just going to be one one and a
half years for the previous money
creation to feed through and then stop
and then inflation will stop
because inflation needs constant
expansion in money creation and you'd
think this is so obvious that when you
have inflation they would actually stop
the money creation but the history shows
no they keep going and they keep
creating more money sadly but we're
talking about the scenario where you do
nothing and you don't increase the money
supply well then also the inflation
would stop after one and a half years
okay so you're saying if i this is just
clarification that
okay guys it'll take about a year and a
half let your strong local bank support
local economies that 1.4 trillion was
like food poisoning and you got to get
it through the body you got to go throw
it you go to the bathroom you got to get
it through it but once it's through
largely
all these things are returned to nominal
and inflation on things everything from
milk to gasoline which hurts the average
person is going to moderate is that what
you're saying it's about that's right a
year and a half that's right and
historically speaking pat what's very
interesting if you look back even the
great recessions
not depressions but great recessions
have usually only been about 18 months
and so you're saying that historical
norms that the peak impact of the
recession because remember there's a lot
that happens into it but when we all
admit yeah crap it's a recession 18
months that's what you're saying 18
months yes yeah okay
that is the lead time that's also why in
2020 i was forecasting significant
inflation to hit us one and a half years
later which is you know which has been
this year
it also goes with the thought that says
all sessions are three years
from the moment you know something's
happening and you don't admit it
politically pat you know like you know
milk is going up gas is going up but you
don't admit it no it'll be like janet
yellen a year and a half ago just
speaking to tv oh yeah maybe a month or
so two months
so from that moment to when we really
see growth again is a 36 month cycle and
what we really have in the united states
is we have a year of denial by the
political
folks that are that are speaking to
voters so there's a year of denial then
there's 18 months of oh my god this is
real
and then
we have evidence of growth yeah and of
course the problem has been lack of
accountability you know if you take
wrong which is the year of there is
accountability at the voting booth which
is why you start with a year of denial
but not by this you know there's no
accountability of the central planners
the ecb has been saying oh there's no
inflation it's transitory you know
they're all speaking the same reading of
the same script well they need to be
held accountable so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]
you